I am going for that Liverpool team right
because they saved my summer okay they
saved my because Tottenham could have
won it right and you know yeah dodgy
dodgy pen that was never if it wer for
them right it would have been the worst
summer of all time imagine Tottenham
would have won the Champions League
before Arsenal right and for that alone
I'm putting them through no no way you I
mean I'm not even going for stats on
this it's an amazing team I can't I
can't F that at all and I'm not bitter
because of what happened yeah no but for
me with a trouble winning team just
don't all right so you're going to lock
in Manny 1999 you're going to lock in
2019 Liverpool Liverpool man so this is
going to go to the sport BLB audience so
Liverpool overall got 4% of the vote out
all the teams here okay man united 99
got 14% of the vote so unfortunately
you've lost out on this one Manny 99 99
are going through to the next round that
Liverpool team I still got a lot of love
for you man